[Music]
everybody is Charlie this is gonna be my
West world episode 9 video careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet this
is the last one before the finale so
obviously some big payoffs so many holy
crap moment so let's go through top 10
WTF and Easter eggs if you're just
finding my channel for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
but the title of the episode was
vanishing point which is sort of like a
reference and art in culture to the
converging of different lines so it's
kind of a meta reference to all the
different story lines converging on the
forge in the finale
we also learned too that the valley
beyond is really called the forge I
think we all kind of already understood
that it was a supercharged version of
the cradle but they just sort of called
it out very specifically as that during
the episode but number 10 we finally
meet the man in blacks wife played by
the very famous Sela Ward so very big
celebrity casting she did an amazing job
with her performance tour-de-force
but you knew where this was headed
because we already got that flashback to
him running up the stairs with the tub
running her killing herself so we knew
it was all building towards that climax
vanishing point the title of the episode
converging storylines that moment her
killing herself converging with Teddy
killing himself in the man in black
almost killing himself so whenever you
thought of the episodes earlier this
season I feel like they've done a better
job of plotting out these last couple of
ones I think it's because they have to
pay off so much plot so there's not a
lot of time for them to wander around I
laughed a little bit when they kept
referencing Alexander the Great and
those Plutarch quotes now she quotes it
correctly like she actually read it but
obviously the man in black probably
thinks of himself as Alexander the Great
weeping because there are so many worlds
to conquer the actual true quote is that
Alexander wept when he found out that
there were infinite worlds and he had
barely begun to conquer the one the
forge representing the infinite
possibilities that he's going to learn
about probably in next week's episode
but number nine the ghost nation finally
makes their stand against Deloris kind
of fruitfully it doesn't seem like
they're a whole lot of them there so
there's probably not the entire ghost
nation but they were setting that up in
last week's episode like the whole idea
was is that akita was going to try and
stop dolores from reaching the valley
beyond because
recognize how poisonous her mission was
this is the worst thing ever we don't
want this bloodshed to spill into the
next world they do a really good job of
setting up that Teddy twist like even
though he's been forcibly changed by
Dolores he still rejects the programming
but it does look like it's really hard
for him to do so this is probably why he
had that speech of the N breeze like oh
yeah I could definitely never hurt you
because of the metaphor of the way he
was programmed like literally programmed
to care for her but also because it's
become deeper than that it's sort of
their relationship getting to that
territory where Maeve is with her
daughter where it's like she's
programmed to love the daughter but also
like on a fundamental level as she gains
awareness she really genuinely does care
about her number a this is actually a
pretty cool twist Charlotte using
Maeve's
god mode to turn the hosts on each other
like just full-on massacre like it was
really crazy you see Clementine there
looking like she kind of understands
what's going on there's this weird
haunted look in her eyes like she's not
supposed to know what's going on but you
always sense like there's this deeper
awareness inside her head even though
most of this season has been other
people controlling her like Dolores
using her like a finger puppet and now
Charlotte using her like a finger puppet
to spread this virus code using their
mesh networking ability number seven
that flashback to four to the bar with
man in black no I think one final game
just teasing what we heard from young
Ford host at the beginning of the season
there's one last game for you to play
the real brilliant thing about Ford's
plan I think the metaphor starting to
emerge is very similar to what Ford is
doing to Bernard
so he's forcing Bernard to evolve by
giving him all this pain remember how
pain is very important for hosts
awakening so it seems like Ford is
forcing Bernard to kill all these people
in the Mesa and do these terrible things
I don't want to kill any more people it
seems like he's just doing this in order
to give Bernard a lot of pain to force
him to awaken but also when it really
met away the final game for William also
seems like it's a reverse version of
that he gave him his profile card which
seemed kind of weird because William
could have gotten that himself so why
would he give it to him if he hadn't
calculated the chain of events that
would lead to where William is today so
it's sort of like Ford knew in real life
what might happen giving him this
profile card allow
to fall into the hands of his wife so in
the way that everybody has been playing
Ford's game this whole time he's been
controlling the part even after his
death this whole time and he's also sort
of been pushing man in black around in
real life so we'll talk about this more
a little bit towards the end of the
video but think about the idea of the
man in black experiencing pain in that
forcing him to awaken in a meta way the
way that the hosts awaken in a literal
way to consciousness the beauty of The
Wizard of Oz quote - is that it's very
funny yeah like he's kind of like The
Wizard of Oz what's oz doing without its
wizard but if you know the truth of The
Wizard of Oz like he's really just a
charlatan that sort of passing himself
off like this Grand Wizard the funny
thing about this game that he sets up
for William is that a lot of it is
sleight of hand there's no magic
involved no special code it's just sort
of precipitating events that will cause
a series of dominoes to topple over so
that the man in black starts to
experience all this pain and wake up but
number six Williams daughter reveals the
real reason she wants into the forge is
because she wants to expose everything
and then lock him up the same way he
locked up James Delos and their mother
so more theorizing about what might
happen to William at the end of the
season if he actually does complete the
task of becoming his digital self in
achieving this immortality
she references logan again there were
actually several times that logan was
referenced during the episode like his
wife referenced him in passing rumor he
killed himself a long time ago through
drug use but it's also them sort of
setting up the finale I'll do a trailer
video tomorrow because there's a whole
bunch of footage where they sort of
close a lot of the loops that they set
up at the beginning of the season number
five the flashback to his wife actually
killing herself I love the way they shot
it we'd already gotten teases of it
they'd weave parts of it into the
episode so we knew they were building to
this moment so it was just a question of
how they were gonna pay that off in what
led to that moment so we learned all
about the profile card her learning the
truth of everything him revealing the
one truth that she had asked him about
and it was basically that he had thought
that he was evil this whole time and has
just been slowly letting it leak out
like I tried to build a wall but you saw
right through it when he says that I
belong to another world he's obviously
talking about the park the really cool
cut that they added in this was when he
saw Dolores at the end of season
one and went full man in black after
realizing that she didn't remember him
nothing is real this is all meaningless
like that just totally drove him crazy
but if it wasn't clear this scene right
here that was him
seeing Dolores right after he had sent
Logan off naked on that horse he came
back to town and Dolores just picked up
the can and was like hello stranger
beginning her new loop so that also kind
of explains later how Williams daughter
got his profile card like she found it
in the little music box that she had
referenced earlier in the episode she
thought that had been destroyed because
she threw it in the trash but number
four this is so crazy
William kills the Delos rescue team and
tries to kill his daughter I think you
know tries is very important I don't
think she's actually dead I think they
just want you to think that she might be
dead convinced that they're all hosts
being controlled by Ford what I think is
going on here like the reason why he's
obviously digging around in himself
because he thinks that he might be hosts
are my choices my own am I even real
what's going on what is real like he's
trying to prove to himself that he's
actually a real person this is probably
him slowly becoming conscious like
building towards a climax the same way
that Bernards story is building towards
a climax so she'd go without saying that
I think that his daughter is alive but
she's just on the edge of death we'll
probably see her again during the finale
but number three like I said Bernard vs.
Ford all because I think Ford is trying
to force him to do these terrible things
to make him awake in fully like Bernard
says I'm the only one that can stop this
have to get rid of you and Ford agrees
with him he's like you're definitely the
only person that can save the day but I
feel like you know as he exists right
now in his current state of
consciousness Ford thinks that Bernard
can't do it he has to forcibly evolve
the rest of the way and the only way to
do that is to experience a certain level
of trauma and that's why he's trying to
get him to kill LC like I don't think
that Ford actually cares whether or not
LC lives or dies he's just trying to
push Bernard to evolve number two is
that really beautiful scene with Ford
and Maeve where he gives her that one
final gift and this is really nice
metaphor where he talks about how proud
he is of her how he underestimated her
because she stayed in the park to save
her daughter and he did the same thing
revealing that he stayed inside this
sort of digital space like he preserved
his consciousness so that he
could save his children too but I think
we kind of knew that but they make it a
more literal thing here when he's
talking to her like you're my favorite
daughter here's my final gift to you and
sort of unlocks like whatever the final
barrier is to giving her true God mode
but as you see all the footage for is
still technically around so it's not
like she's replacing for it or anything
like that number one of course has to be
Teddy killing himself in projection of
Dolores the way they edited this was so
beautiful too with the silent scream in
the way the music rose like Dolores is
in complete horror because they
genuinely did love each other and that's
why Teddy killed himself he explains no
I realize I could never hurt you because
of the way I care about you but also
because of his base programming so the
only way he can fight her is by killing
himself so that she can't continue to
use him like a tool to execute her will
he doesn't want to be her terminator
anymore that really beautiful speech
that he went out on to was also the same
speech that they would give each other
when they would talk about running away
together we'll do it someday we'll get
out of here it's sort of the same way
that they let Angela go out with a twist
on her dialogue her core speech about
welcoming people into West world but
like I said obviously there's a whole
bunch of footage from the finale I'll do
a trailer video for that tomorrow let me
know what was your favorite part of the
episode and post all your theories in
the comments obviously there's still so
much left to be revealed but like I said
I think that they sort of tipped their
hat as to what Ford's plan for the man
in black is like he wants to help redeem
him and turn him back into a good person
whether or not you think that's possible
but it's also sort of parallel with
Bernards arc and you have all these
converging storylines on the forge next
week click here for brand new Game of
Thrones and click here for brand new
ant-man and the wasp and Avengers 4
thank you so much for watching everybody
to stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]